[Music]
on this friday night the death of a
prince
the tributes to prince philip and the
condolences
to the queen she could depend on him in
a way that no one else
could remembering the long life of the
duke of edinburgh he was one of the best
royals
and will the funeral bring another
family drama
kovid 19 reaches a critical point in
canada
put the brakes on get this curve under
control
sounding the alarm as hospitals prepare
for a new onslaught
of cases
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
outside windsor castle tonight tributes
are being left for the duke of edinburgh
and inside queen elizabeth ii is
spending her first night
as a widow the man she married 73 years
ago died in the castle earlier today
her royal duties are now on pause as she
begins eight days
of mourning good evening and thanks for
joining us buckingham palace says prince
philip died peacefully this morning
he was just two months shy of his 100th
birthday
the official announcement was made just
after 12 p.m
local time we are interrupting our
normal programmes to bring you
an important announcement in a statement
the palace said
it is with deep sorrow that her majesty
the queen announces the death of her
beloved husband
his royal highness the prince philip
duke of edinburgh
he met and outlived a multitude of world
leaders and spent decades traveling the
world carrying out royal duties leaving
an impression on everyone he met
former u.s president barack obama wrote
today the duke was kind and warm with a
sharp wit
and unfailing good humor australia's
prime minister said phillip
embodied a generation we will never see
again
prince philip met nearly every canadian
prime minister since 1952
including prime minister pierre trudeau
and his son
justin i had the privilege of knowing
prince philip
almost my entire life the first times i
met him
i was just a kid here in ottawa many
years ago
but obviously over the past few years
i've had the opportunity to have
a few more conversations with him and
it is a tremendous personal as well as
public sorrow that we all share prince
philip's death was not a complete
surprise he had been sick for weeks yet
his
passing has struck a chord with many and
represents the beginning of the end of
an
era in the british monarchy our europe
bureau chief crystal gamansing is
outside
windsor castle for us tonight crystal
donna it has been an emotional day here
in windsor you know as people reflected
on prince phillips life
many got choked up and and a number
actually shed
tears you know it's after 10 30 at night
here and even still people
are coming by and laying flowers at the
gates of windsor castle
and pausing to reflect not only on the
impact prince phillip had on people here
in the united kingdom
but right around the world
the notice posted on the gates of
buckingham palace was simple
his royal highness passed away
peacefully this morning
at windsor castle it didn't stay up long
the royal family asking that crowds not
gather
because of covid after 99 years
73 of them at the queen's side prince
philip's death
quickly made headlines around the world
a german newspaper calling him the
queen's greatest support
tribute spanning far beyond commonwealth
countries
prince philip earned the affection of
generations
here in the united kingdom across the
commonwealth
and around the world good night granda
the nation wishes you a good sleep to me
he's been part of my life
and his contribution to this country is
enormous
the longest serving royal consort in
british history
prince philip had no official role
always
two steps behind the queen but still
finding a way to make his
mark known as irreverent and funny
the duke of edinburgh liked to laugh i
mean can you get radio 3
over the years he made some major gaps
but never apologized
changed my way in which i react to
things it's it's
it's part of that's somebody's style his
style also included
a great sense of duty philip only
retired from public royal life
four years ago in february he was
hospitalized released
after a month and returned to the queen
at windsor castle
flowers and notes are piling up but the
royal family hopes people pay tribute
in other ways they actually ask them to
make donations to charities to their
favorite charities
or indeed charities the principal it was
involved with so obviously they are very
concerned that they don't want large
crowds gathering and causing a problem
the prince's death comes as the royal
family is fractured philip's grandson
prince harry and his wife megan
living in california after stepping away
from royal life
well one hopes that prince harry is
going to try and get over for the
funeral
but i think harry would very much like
to come over for his grandfather he was
very very fond of him loved him dearly
and this might well be the opportunity
for the family to heal the rift
hope a shared sense of sorrow can
overcome
any split between the generations
crystal if the queen's reign is
considered a success and i think it
widely is
prince philip was really the joint
author of that success
she first met him when she was just a
girl and she'll now finish her last
years as queen
without him it is quite sad isn't it
it really is and that isn't lost on
people here as they express sorrow at
the loss of prince philip
their thoughts quickly turn to the queen
not as the monarch who will continue to
reign alone but
as a woman who lost her husband
prince philip never wanted a state
funeral apparently he didn't want to
fuss and i guess because of covet the
funeral will be scaled back
even more what do we know about the
plans yeah kovit really will
change things as you mentioned he didn't
want a fuss and we are still
waiting for official details but
whatever happens
will be a much smaller gathering as you
mentioned they don't want people leaving
flowers and are encouraging
virtual tributes so we're waiting to
hear those exact details but we do
know that he will be laid to rest here
on the grounds of windsor castle
donna crystal commencing in windsor
tonight thanks
canada always held a special place in
prince philip's heart he visited
this country more than any other eric
sorenson has a look back
at the impact he made in 70 years
philip visited canada more than 70 times
such was his attachment to a country
vast and glorious
niagara falls the first trip with
princess elizabeth before she ascended
to the throne
he was still a navy commander who valued
the canadian military he
very much appreciated and admired
canada's contributions to the second
world war canadian oak hill stewart
born the same year was philip's friend
since their school days in scotland
before he died
stewart recalled philip's passion for
this country with regard to canada
i found him just all gung-ho one step
behind the queen the duke of edinburgh's
relationship with canada was expansive
his devotion to the environment included
the duke of edinburgh
ecological reserve in british columbia
he was a founding member of the world
wildlife
fund i don't think that 10 years ago
people were conscious of the
consequences of some of the things they
were doing
it was very close to his heart from my
point of view his contribution
to wildlife conservation was enormous
his sponsorship of the duke of edinburgh
awards
inspired many young canadians to embrace
public service
setting goals for yourself to achieve
and then digging into yourself i think
maybe prince philip realized
this is something young people might
benefit from
and along the way he just enjoyed this
country from the wretched weather
to the time the royals boat broke down
on manitoba's red river
actually they had a real good chuckle
over the event
from everyday canadians to national
leaders there was a fondness for the
feisty royal
an exceptional individual with a lot of
color
and who played his role as it should be
but he had a way of
expressing himself and
being quite candid the welcome in the
indian villages
much has changed in canada since the
early royal visits to indigenous
communities
the connection to the monarchy is
changing and yet to many
the bonds have lasted oh he's just
beautiful these very personal
connections between
the crown and and first nations people
um that have continued even as
even as the role of the crown in canada
has
changed over the course the 20th and
21st centuries
phillips fellowship with this country
never wavered especially towards
veterans and the military
this was his last visit in 2013. in the
world where there is so much
senseless violence the regiment has an
enviable reputation
for peacekeeping how enduring a kinship
philip was the colonel in chief of the
royal canadian regiment
for 68 years eric sorensen global news
toronto well it is difficult to sum up
99 years
in a few minutes a little later we will
have a deeper look at prince philip's
life
and his 73 year marriage to the queen
now back to the pandemic canada's chief
public health officer says
this country is at a critical point over
the last week hospitalizations for
covid19
increased by seven percent the number of
critical care patients jumped by 23
percent
ontario appears to be in deep trouble
more than 4 200 new infections were
reported there today
and 18 more people died from covet 19.
ontario hospitals have been instructed
to postpone elective and non-urgent
surgeries
to ensure they have the capacity for
covet-19 patients
quebec alberta and b.c are seeing
similar spikes in case counts
manitoba said today it's at the start of
a third wave
and as michael couture reports canada's
chief public health officer says
tighter public health restrictions are
essential
right now put the brakes on
get this curve under control canada's
top doctor
couldn't put it any simpler dr theresa
tam says the modeling shows we are
headed in the wrong direction
as variants spread quicker than vaccines
are going into arms
so she's imploring canadians to respect
public health guidelines
the faster you get on with
these measures the faster you can come
out of them
and it could go even faster as the
vaccine rollout ramps up across the
country
a needle nervous doug ford rolled up his
sleeve today
the ontario premier urged people to
follow the stay-at-home
order while they target so-called hot
zones with vaccines
where we see 60 percent of the cases and
toronto appeal and york
you know we have some issues in those
areas
the rollout has been criticized in those
regions
i feel like i am doing the government's
homework ray lai
volunteers his time to help people
navigate ontario's vaccine booking
system
he's also taken to twitter calling out
the province's rollout
i honestly don't see a plan it is policy
by press conference
it doesn't do anybody in this province a
service at all
and it causes general anxiety that
anxiety made worse by a directive for
ontario hospitals
to ramp down elective and non-emergency
surgeries
as they prepare for an increase of
covid19
hospitalizations and it has the
president of the canadian medical
association
worried people in their in their 30s
in their 40s who are now being admitted
to icu's
and also who are who are dying
dr collins believes kovit 19 variants
have completely changed the ball game
and it's why now more than ever people
need to
follow public health guidelines michael
couture global news ottawa
the united states still has the most
cases of covid19
and the most deaths but if you compare
it to canada and adjust the numbers
based on population
canada's situation doesn't look too rosy
at the start of 2021 both the u.s and
canada were hitting a peak for daily
infections
since then the number of new infections
in the u.s has dropped dramatically
canada's rate of new infection is still
rising on a per capita basis the
countries are nearly on par with each
other
yesterday the u.s reported more than 199
new cases per 1 million people
canada is not far behind 185 new
infections
per 1 million people screening for
variants of concern coming up has their
rise
outpaced canada's ability to track them
for weeks we have been tracking the rise
of the variants the number of covet 19
cases linked to them has more than
doubled in canada in the last week
25 000 variant cases have now been
detected
the b-117 strain the one first
identified in the uk accounts for over
90 percent of them
the only way the variance can be
confirmed is through genomic sequencing
now bc has decided to stop doing
sequencing for every
suspected case robin gill explains why
rogers arena the home of the vancouver
canucks has become a petri dish
allowing kovid 19 to thrive the virus
has infected most of the players
the team's doctor confirms a highly
contagious variant
led to the spread this virus is tricky
it's
changing and we need to change with it
if we could anticipate what it's going
to do next
our jobs would be way easier three
variants are making their way through
bc's population
those uncomfortable nose swabs can't
specify which variant is at work
it takes genomic sequencing to do the
deeper dive
but those tests are complex take time
and they're expensive that's why the
province's top doctor is
putting an end to that extra layer of
testing for every case
we assume that anybody who is positive
with um for covid 19
needs to be treated as if they have one
of these highly transmissible viruses
instead bc will reserve genomic tests
for any unusual clusters in the
community
and for travelers coming from abroad
because the virus will
have more variations carolyn colan
is leading the new national modeling
network she believes there is value in
this new surveillance strategy
we want to understand what our covet
population is
what's our the population of the virus
that we're facing
because that will tell us information
about you know importations
about the viruses diversity about
maybe risks with reinfection as for the
canucks not every player was tested for
the variant but the team just needed one
player to come down with it
to know it was bad we saw how fast
this virus is very contagious the nhl
insist vancouver will finish the season
even though the players are out of
practice robin gill global news
vancouver still ahead a heavy police
presence in northern ireland
along with calls for calm
there's been another night of violence
in northern ireland
despite calls for calm protesters
returned to the streets of belfast
throwing stones and molotov cocktails of
police who used water cannon
to push them back the clashes have
erupted over
long-standing sectarian tensions brought
to life again by
covid by post-brexit trade rules
there are more problems for boeing 737
max
jets boeing has told 16 airlines to
address a
possible electrical fault in some
aircraft before they fly again
the issue was reportedly discovered by
mechanics during production
the 737 max returned to service in
december after being grounded worldwide
in march
2019 changes were made to the automated
flight control system after
it was determined they played a role in
two deadly crashes
he has quite simply been my strength and
stay
all these years next remembering prince
philip who the queen first met
when she was just a girl
[Music]
prince philip was once asked if he was
hoping to reach 100
and he said good god no i can't imagine
anything worse
he said bits of me are falling off
already
he did end up outliving nearly everyone
who knew him and
might be able to explain him those who
are still left describe him
as an unsentimental realist and a
pragmatist he fell in love with his
future wife way back in the 1940s
and that union shaped both the man and
the monarchy
here's jeff semple
on their golden 50th wedding anniversary
back in 1997
the queen gave a rare speech a public
deeply personal tribute to her husband
and i and his whole family and
this and many other countries owe him a
debt
greater than he would ever claim or we
shall ever know
for more than seven decades he stood by
her majesty's side
always a step behind prince philip holds
a unique place in history
no one else served so long as the spouse
of a reigning monarch
they're very much a team and in the
later years they
they really were dependent on each other
much more than we saw
in public behind the scenes of course he
uh he was always head of the family
wore the trousers in private not bad for
a man who wasn't even british
born in greece as a member of the greek
and danish royal families
but after a military coup his family was
banished
in 1939 on the eve of war philip
enlisted in the british royal navy
and during his training was assigned to
watch over his distant cousin
princess elizabeth they exchanged
letters for seven years
and after the war philip asked king
george for permission
to marry his oldest daughter as onto the
famous balcony came
the bride and bridegroom their wedding
in westminster abbey was broadcast to
200 million people around the world
the newlyweds never expected princess
elizabeth was about to become queen
but after her father died suddenly in
1952
she was thrust onto the throne philip
forced to give up his promising naval
career
to assume the full-time job of prince
consort
while elizabeth appeared shy and
reserved phillip was
friendly and even funny i hope you had a
good breakfast this morning because we
may not be through until about tea time
this evening
well i think obviously when he first
started there were quite a few people in
establishment as i say who didn't really
like him
they died away and as time went on of
course he
got older and older and was very much
the establishment himself
and i think he just became more and more
popular with the public mainly for his
outspoken views but those views also got
him into trouble
whole books were written about his
penchant for eyebrow raising remarks
like the time he asked indigenous
australians if they still threw spears
and he was infamously impatient with the
british press
are you well sir do i look ill his
famous stubborn streak was on full
display at the queen's diamond jubilee
pageant in 2012
the 90 year old prince stood in the cold
rain for hours
landing himself in hospital with a
bladder infection
but the duke bounced back visiting
toronto for a quick solo visit in 2013
his final trip to canada we're now going
to see the world's most experienced
place
even into his 90s the royal workhorse
carried out more public engagements than
harry will and kate
combined supporting nearly 800 different
charities
[Music]
in 2017 at the age of 96
prince philip carried out his final
public engagement
before retiring from royal duties but
was still
spotted at family events including the
royal wedding of prince harry and meghan
markle
which phillip attended despite still
recovering from hip surgery
philip is survived by his growing family
children grandchildren and
great-grandchildren
including three generations of future
kings
all heirs to the british throne his
legacy
includes more than 22 000 solo public
engagements and a lifetime of service to
his adopted country
and to the woman who was both his queen
and
his wife he is someone who doesn't
take easily to compliments but he has
quite simply been my strength and stay
all these years and that is global
national for this friday i'm donna
friesen
prince philip made over 70 trips to
canada over his lifetime we leave you
with images
of some of them thanks for watching
you